hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Star Wars rebels episode 6 video
it was basically like the imagery from
Empire Strikes Back laid on top of pitch
black you know that old Vin Diesel movie
I was really happy to get a harris
sabine episode little disappointed with
the execution just because there was so
much talking very little actual doing
stuff we did get some more Sabine
backstory from her time on Mandalore
I'd say the Mandalorians probably my
favorite race and all of Star Wars
careful for spoilers though if you're
not cut up on the episode starting with
top five moments number five no pilot in
the Imperial fleet can outrun Hera this
was just the start of one of many lines
from Empire Strikes Back like lines of
dialogue that whole opening chasing was
just them taking lines from Empire
Strikes Back from different characters
for instance we've gotten ourselves into
another fine mess that was a Princess
Leia line
I think Ezra had a line for the movies
too they do that a lot on Star Wars
rebels where they take lines of dialogue
from the original trilogy and give them
to the characters it's fun when I spot
it but I don't feel like they need to do
it quite so much I kind of wonder how
much their target audience like the
little kids that this shows actually
made for have actually seen the original
trilogy probably not that many it's like
when you say Star Wars to a lot of
younger Millennials they just think of
the Clone Wars like they don't think of
the movies as much it's just funny when
you think about how generational Star
Wars is everyone has a different
reference point for the franchise number
four Harris Secrets explained so Sabine
is really pissed that they're not
explaining who their source of Intel is
really the interesting thing when they
were arguing in the cockpit was learning
a little bit more about the process by
which they choose missions it's just a
callback to the birth of the rebellion
they're looking for missions missions
that will allow them to steal stuff from
the empire that they can then turn
around as a prophet so it's like a
slightly more honorable version of what
Han and Chewie were doing I mean there
were just straight-up smugglers they
didn't really care about the rebellion
when we first met him I did laugh just a
little bit when they used the name
fulcrum as her source
just because I'm Chuck if you remember
that TV show from a couple years ago
fulcrum was like a really big evil
organization fulcrum was like that shows
version of the empire that doesn't
necessarily mean that Hera's contact is
evil it's just what happens to your
brain when you watch too much TV number
three's Sabine's backstory the series
hasn't spent a whole lot of time
explaining her character I think we'll
get more episodes that'll deal with her
backstory but we know she's Mandalorian
we know she quit the Imperial Academy
she's an explosives expert so presumably
she had to blow up some people that she
didn't want to blow up her big thing in
the episode was not following orders
blindly so I'm guessing that she was
ordered to kill someone she blew up a
bunch of innocent people which is
interesting because she killed those
stormtroopers with the bomb in the first
episode and didn't seem too bad my lash
Mandalorians are renowned for their
warrior prowess so I'm interested to see
more about what's going on in her head
most of my experience with the
Mandalorians though is through the
expanded universe comics so through the
Dark Horse Comics like Knights of the
Old Republic
I know between Clone Wars in the
expanded universe the backstory for the
Mandalorians has changed quite a bit
though number two pitchblack
star wars edition so if you haven't seen
it there's a Vin Diesel movie called
pitch black it's part of the Riddick
trilogy there's pitch black Chronicles
of Riddick
and then just Riddick in the first movie
pitch black there in the shuttlecraft to
get stranded on a planet that alternates
between day and night and whenever it's
night like these crazy monsters come out
and just start ripping people to shreds
it was almost the exact same plot of
that movie coupled with plants vs.
zombies it's just that whenever they
were setting up those charges and waves
you know for waves of monsters it felt
like a setup for a mobile game don't be
surprised if you see like a Star Wars
mobile game modeled after this episode
at some point that might be Disney
marketing at work very insidious and my
number one moment
Rhodian Lobot in the end credits teaser
it's funny that the in credits teaser
was my favorite moment from this episode
I felt like it was actually really
promising but just didn't deliver like
it was way too preachy
I don't mind dialogue heavy episodes
like where characters just sit and talk
to each other but it was like Hera was
giving Sabine a lecture like you were
stuck in a lecture in a class on a
Sunday the thing is is that children
have relatively short attention span so
anytime characters talk for longer than
like a minute or two I feel like people
tune out so that's why I thought it was
weird that there was so much talking in
this episode I know I mentioned The
Empire Strikes Back visual imagery I
totally enjoyed that part of the episode
especially the base they were on and
then you have a big clone war shout out
plus there was the moment when they
shocked the hall to get
little bug off like whenever the Falcon
was escaping the space worm let me know
that what was your favorite moment from
the episode and which of the characters
do you want to learn more about now I
feel like Hera is actually one of the
more interesting ones overall I gave the
episode to see which is like the lowest
rating I think I've given any TV show or
movie all season long I feel like it's
starting to get a little too caught up
in the pratfalls namely with chopper
chopper is being used as a comedic
device but I feel like he's coming
across more is like someone you'd want
to crush like you just want someone to
blow him up he really was annoying in
this episode especially when Ezra jumped
on him and they just started spinning
around I just felt it was way too
ridiculous they even recycled the joke
later in the episode they did the exact
same thing in the mess hall all over
poor Zeb's waffles at least it looked
like he was trying to eat waffles let's
call him space waffles I do like the
relationship they're developing between
Hera and Sabine it's kind of like big
sister little sister
I didn't think Kara's old enough to be
your mother we haven't seen a lot of
Ezra Sabine bonding yet even though it's
implied that they're friendly although
she did kind of shoot him down I'm kind
of glad they're not doing the ships
thing although I feel like that's
inevitable like at some point there will
be like an ESRI Sabine ship moment where
they'll be like stuck together in space
and they'll have like some weird awkward
romantic moment like I said though next
week roadie and Lobot so I'm hoping it's
gonna be a lot more interesting than
this episode or at least the action will
be a little bit more interesting be sure
to subscribe to my video I'll try and
post it next week I know I've been
posting rebels videos around Thursdays
don't forget new Legend of Korra
tomorrow morning so that'll be my next
video in the meantime you can click here
to catch up on Legend of Korra and you
can click here to catch up on rebels
thank you so much for watching so that's
all high five and I will see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]